uh I got real lucky Milo was being born
meaning meaning I was born in the Soviet
Union a [ __ ] place with the worst the
worst place on earth to be born in 1975
or minimally one of the worst places and
definitely the worst place at scale to
be born in the world was where I was
born right we didn't have [ __ ] and and
so I emigrated to the u.s. we had
nothing I was poor I didn't speak
English I went outside and Dover New
Jersey I never talked about this I was
picked on heavily kids forced me to
drink pee out of a Pepsi can I was 4
foot 11 my freshman year of high school
not good
I was short I couldn't you know my home
my infrastructure me like my life I met
three of my four grandparents died
before I was born right so I didn't have
that my dad worked every minute I never
saw him because we had to make it in
America
so no dad in the equation had the best
mom of all time so that equally is why
I'm here
have the greatest mom of all time so you
know and so my I have a chip on my
shoulder I'm an underdog
I wasn't born in this awesome country
everybody here had a quicker Head Start
than I did you know what I mean and so
being an immigrant and and being small
like I think I I genuinely believe when
I think about it being an immigrant went
away eventually right by third grade I
was an American it was it was you know
for boys you know being under five foot
going into high school that's some good
adversity you know and then and then
manufacturing it right I love underdogs
I when the gym when the Yankees and the
Rangers won championships I stopped
being a fan I'm actually anti bandwagon
you know like like I don't wanna when my
team's win I abandon them like literally
like literally I've not watched the full
Yankee or Ranger game since they won
their championships but I love the Jets
and Knicks I'm hardwired for the
underdog I hated Tiger Woods when he was
America's Sweetheart he goes in the
[ __ ] I love Tiger Woods I hated Kobe
Bryant when he was the best basketball
player in the world the last two years I
loved Kobe because he's
finished I loved it like that's who I am
so my hardwiring Mike my ethos
Who I am is adversity is underdog I won
the wine world I won the wine business
world
how did I do what did I do with that I
left it and came into an industry where
I was nothing and everybody made fun of
me I'm Twitter boy I have a lot of
Twitter followers I'm gonna start an
agency and now I'm [ __ ] sticking it to
their faces right and I'm and now I'm
almost done and another five or seven
years I'll build the undisputed great
agency of this generation and you know
how I'm gonna handle that not by cashing
in and [ __ ] laying on a beach I'm
gonna I'm gonna do what I always do
which is walk directly away from it and
start a new challenge where I'm the
underdog wait he can't do that that has
nothing to do don't forget what I did I
went from the wine retail business to
the advertising agent that had no
connection and so you know I don't know
I'm gonna go win a [ __ ] Golden Globe
or something